WK & z
that's how you do it on a Wednesday more
than [__] uncle Joey here
January Wednesday 25th who the [__] do
you think you're dealing with
most of these little has the facts it's
hump day I'm not feeling it won't have a
big dick up your ass you feel that
except you ain't got time to feel
nothing everybody wants to feel sorrow I
don't feel it what you need to feel we
need two feels a black dick up your ass
you [__] Mambo it's time to rock
[__] it's Wednesday night we gotta go
deep into the murky waters on a day like
this you got jujitsu you got meetings
you got push-ups you got [__] emails
you got a ton of [__] to send not even
not even including your [__] goals
for the day
what are you gold what do you want from
[__] today I wanna get high I wanna
eat some chicken college and I want to
makes try to do that by hanging around
the couch watching you go [__] [__]
games no by getting up and telling these
[__] who's running [__] sorry I
got a little [__] carried away there
look at that right there for you smoking
some [__] heat today we got some
classic [__]
oh gee we got the na og I mean you know
it's just one of those days here if you
gotta get out then [__] shoot the
horse this is what you need to smoke I'm
saying if you wanna go up there and you
[__] friends at Starbucks huh talk
about equality you gotta earn equality
[__] you gotta earn it [__]
ain't nobody gonna give you nothing my
early years I was a [__] thief I stole
everything and then I stopped being a
thief but I started being a [__] life
teeth if you want some go take it that's
it stop [__] around some day my
[__] some day go [__] put your blast
back now
take a look listen put it in your pocket
before somebody else will alright
[__] that's the [__] more pick
it up and put it in your pocket before
somebody else will you follow me what'll
you spot the most if they worried about
Trump if they're worried about
themselves as much as they want to put
on Facebook [__] about Trump in society
and all this [__] they'd be [__]
millionaires if they worried about
everything that was going on as much as
yourself said listen since the age of
[__] 28:29 I don't give a [__] about
me
as a sensation of movie you have to see
gives a [__] those distractions you dumb
[__]
but then you want to sit this ace the
ball ain't bouncing my way why not
because you're too busy standing on line
for a movie and hang out with your
[__] creepy [__] friends flop all
those [__] you see anybody here
in the morning [__] no solo like a
[__] wolf all my [__] life solo
when you come out of your mom snatch
it's you on that little cord once they
cut that snatch your solo [__]
so stop your [__] crying get that
reefer get that notebook get those
[__] push-ups and they all gotta suck
you there
am i lying to you in my mind did you
want them to pay attention to you blow
something up
not literally blow something up and
they'll [__] know who the [__] you
are
plain and simple Illinois seek it and
get that mom and IP yeah oh yeah get it
can I see that took me wire it with me
you'll say copy thunderbolt air to let
me see cam I didn't get my mom and I
think I totally have a long way to
compile but yeah come Wednesday you
gotta come out to jump heavy cuz the
rest of these [__] it Billy
down yeah thank God it warmed up today
what gives a [__] you still got to do
what you do whether it's 22 below with
penguins or it's 155 with [__] get
him that's it
we think we should do another [__]
ball or you want to go home and go to
therapy talk about [__] therapy the
[__] is wrong with you people
you know my therapy is right here this
[__] pollutes I smoked this and I
think about where I went wrong and how
am I correct my mistakes I'm gonna sit
there and talk to some [__] guy for a
deuce or now well I have to say that
[__] outta here just wrong with these
[__] people what is wrong with these
[__] people and they wonder why when
this data speak you know stocks are up
you know this is done stupidly is
[__] up what I'm telling weed I think
we smoked and disappeared
let's do one more what the [__] we gotta
do your way where you gonna go let's do
one more and then we got that tip-top
Magoo ain't nobody never stop it tell
him uncle Joey since you don't give a
[__] you showing up with two balls and a
big cup and you serve them lunch okay
you know what's on the menu yum yum
juice I have to return the menu [__]
copy today
alright and beside that that's it we're
gonna smoke this ball you're gonna go
write your [__] goals you're gonna
write down how you're gonna figure out
today you know [__] them you're scared
you got to manage your fear [__] don't
be scared I'm scared every [__]
there's smoke three of these I'm like
[__] Godzilla and you're Japan they
don't say so get it together
nice it's a beautiful day to be alive we
have each other
worst case scenario we got each other
I'm the uncle Joey
you know that's his day one if not you
wouldn't be like a [__] duck tulips
I'm your uncle [__] okay you
don't even listen to nobody else listen
to me I don't give a [__] if you do I'm
just trying to tell you how
[__] how it is when I blow
smoke up your ass why plug up your
different I'm telling you you could do
whatever the [__] you wanna do don't let
these [__] hold you back
take the distractions out there's a how
much Trump give you every amp and
Hillary give you how many Bretton that
nobody gives you nothing
you're a [__] Savage
if me is to realize I'm telling you that
for free today's your lucky [__] back
get the rabbit's foot to step on [__] do
what you need to do that is you're lucky
they go out there and tell them all to
suck your dick how I caught it and I'm
saying and they won't [__] with you
again and that's it and that's it and
that's that we got a podcast later
o'clock to them I'm in Nashville
Tennessee next Thursday rather say these
don't be [__] around beat it and Lana
Charlotte I don't even know if I'm going
to the places this year so if you're
[__] saying is you want to come and
hang out with uncle Joey come on down
next week we'll rock together you
understand me I'm ready for [__]
Nashville and beside that that's it and
that's that I hope you have a great day
I hope you're safe I hope you're healthy
I hope you keep your eyes open and look
out for these creepy [__] and
[__] like that and that's it nothing but
balls and [__] right there that's it
I love all [__] stay black see you
tonight at a club only nobody [__] with
you today